welcome to apogee up close
webcast series today we'll be uh
discussing a topic that is uh very
popular today
and we'll have an opportunity to do a qa
q a
at the end of the webcast so
let me introduce myself my name is joey
wong i'm the customer engineer
for apogee which is a part of google
cloud
and with me i have i am sarthak i'm a
partner engineer for google cloud
platform
and interestingly i um i was part of
apogee
until last year so i have seen both
sides of the world and we are joining in
from not sunny and but cold new york
it is certainly getting colder um so
today we'll actually be discussing a
couple of items and really it's about
how organizations are actually embarking
on a journey and transition
from a traditionally on premise to a
hybrid
it architecture and some of those
challenges that are faced in that
journey itself
will also present how apogee can help do
risk in some cases accelerate
application modernization and migration
by introducing an api management layer
to
broker transactions between legacy
backend systems and cloud services
so join us as we share how we can help
you make that move to the cloud
so before we get down into the details
itself
interestingly enough google itself
conducts a survey with our customers
and our ci customer cios you know some
of the biggest questions
are are they currently using a
multi-cloud strategy
and based on that survey the response
has
been very eye-opening based on the
server itself
96 of the cios and the customers that we
actually talked to today
have actually either deployed or are
working on deploying or are thinking
seriously about a multi-cloud strategy
and the reasons for these are you know a
number of
number of key points really it's really
about empowering the organization to mix
and match
uh solutions and to be able to leverage
innovative technologies from the
different cloud
providers themselves every single one of
our customers have some unique
requirements which then need they need
to then tailor their solutions based on
those requirements
and additionally it's really to increase
redundancy
and avoid downtime and to ensure that
their business is highly available
and also scalable and we see this a lot
in our financial services customers and
also our healthcare customers as well
so as our customers are actually
embarking on this journey to cloud
there are multiple ways of migration
it's not
a single path to cloud and um you know
when we have a look at it when they
start
with legacy on-premise there are
actually a number of options that they
can take
they can modernize on-premise where they
can start taking some of those
applications that are
monolith applications whether they're
commercially uh off-the-shelf
sort of applications or something that
they built in-house
and start breaking down into you know
smaller
microservices and taking that
microservices architecture approach
when they do that they also have the
ability then take
those modernized applications
microservices and whatnot
and then move to the cloud now not every
single application
can be broken down into microservices so
one of the strategies that our customers
take is the lift and shift where they
take existing model
applications and then move it into the
cloud itself
now that doesn't necessarily bring all
the
advantages of cloud naturally but it
does reduce
your operational overhead it does reduce
the cost of having to procure
new hardware it does reduce the need to
keep up with
upgrade cycles you know patching up the
os and whatnot
so there are some advantages of just
doing lift and shift
and interestingly enough it's never just
you know one way
which is modernized on-prem and then
move to cloud or lift and shift
and then move to the cloud and then
modernize it's usually somewhere in
between
where you know within the same company
even within the same organization
they actually do both where they start
modernizing on-prem
and also start lifting and shifting
certain workloads
into the cloud for folks that aren't
familiar with apogee
apigee is an api management platform
which provides
the ability for you to create api
proxies
and facades which sit in front of your
back-end systems
such as you know cloud applications
legacy on-premise applications
commercially off-the-shelf applications
that have been traditionally deployed uh
on premise
now when we create that facade through
apogee
you get a number of uh you know
capabilities such as security
uh analytics and visibility into who is
actually now
calling into those apis and back-end
systems
you have the ability to publish those
apis into developer portal
for internal and external consumption
thereby
you know creating an additional channel
for consumption
for your business now the benefit of
being able to do this
is your applications that consume your
apis
do not need to know where those apis are
actually implemented
whether they're on premise in the cloud
application a
application b or even versions of those
same applications itself
this is very powerful as it helps our
customers you know create an ability to
then
plan what they want to move and
modernize into the cloud itself so
let's take a look at an example of this
today
you might start off with an on-premise
data center where you have existing
workloads
itself you can now leverage google cloud
platform
to either
[Music]
build new greenfield applications or
even to
even experiment right you can start with
non-production workloads
or even start looking at things like
cloud bursting where you use google
cloud to
supplement your on-premise resources as
you get comfortable with
google cloud platform we can then start
doing things like lift and shift
as we saw in the previous slides when we
take those existing on-premise
applications and then deploy
them onto google cloud itself using
something like
google compute engine the other strategy
which was to modernize in place
so breaking down existing applications
into microservices
and leveraging things like kubernetes on
premise
where you have now you know created
these microservices which can then be
deployed into kubernetes
which can then be scaled automatically
through command in a kubernetes
itself with those modernized
microservices
that have been deployed or developed on
kubernetes itself
we can then easily migrate them to
google cloud platform
and more specifically into google
kubernetes and
gke so at the end of the day
you know all these efforts are really
for the applications at the front end
consuming
the apis itself so where we see api
management helping
is sitting between the two um
infrastructures whether it's on-premise
or in the cloud
which then provides that facade and
protects the consumers from
needing to know specifically where they
need to consume the apis from
so with that what are some of the
challenges that our customers
are actually experiencing when they
think about modernization and migration
to the cloud itself
they think about business continuity
right as they move
applications to the cloud they should
not
cause any outage or disruption to their
existing customers and this can be
customers from internal
and could be customers from an external
point of view they also need to consider
security because data in
you know inherently will live in
multiple places and be accessed uh
in multiple places as well you don't
want to be compromised
or you know leave apis open for
consumption without any control or
visibility which brings us to visibility
without an api management layer it
becomes very difficult to understand
you know who your consumers are be able
to control which applications are
actually consuming
those apis and understand are they
consuming them in a
fashion that you actually want them to
and then interoperability as well
as you lift and shift certain
applications you want to maintain
you know applications that are
traditionally more familiar with
things like soap web services and
continue to be able to offer those
things up in the easy
and consumable fashion itself and lastly
you want to be able to handle unmanaged
services you know traditionally as you
build out microservices
or applications itself how do you
actually understand
you know those those consumptions of
those services themselves without
some sort of visibility without some
sort of api management layer it becomes
very
difficult as you scale out
so how can apogee help so in terms of
service connectivity
and helping business continuity we
can create that abstraction layer
between
gcp and also on-premise itself
we can create that abstraction layer
between you know legacy application
and modernized applications themselves
we hide the complexity of the
application migration
because your consumers no longer need to
know
where those new services or legacy
services live they can continue to
consume the way that they
used to with api management you now have
the ability to also enforce
security consistently across all your
apis
you can also use apogee to facilitate
things like mediation between security
protocols
and that's something that we'll discuss
with a particular customer use case
in a in a couple more minutes we get
great visibility
because now all traffic is being proxied
through
apogee itself we capture every aspect of
that api transaction
where the api transaction has been
called from
which application how often they're
actually consuming the apis
and you know what sort of performance
and error rates you're actually seeing
this gives you a great visibility into
understanding your api program
and also be able to improve extend your
api program itself
we give you api facades where you can
modernize legacy
software applications turn them into new
api
restful apis and also you know give you
consistency across the board and lastly
service management across all your micro
services or even your traditional
legacy applications where you now have a
single platform
where you can enforce policies across
the board
across all those different services and
then be able to manage it in a single
pane of glass what are the solutions
benefits
in terms of being able to leverage
apogee in this particular use case
is that you're reducing the risk of app
migration and modernization
by creating an api facade you have the
ability to provide
a consistent api across the board for
both you know modernized
services and legacy services itself at
the same time you can then start
leveraging
um you know innovative technologies in
the cloud
so start innovating on gcp by leveraging
things like gke
ai i ml etc where those
services sit shouldn't matter to the api
consumers themselves or the applications
apigee will now mediate and make sure
that
it is routed to the appropriate
endpoints so
with that i would like to
start talking about a specific customer
use case and
sartech was actually involved with a
particular customer
that actually embarked on this
particular journey so with that
so i think do you want to introduce the
actual use case itself
yeah absolutely so this is something i
think i worked on maybe
a year or so ago maybe a little bit more
than that at this stage
uh when we started first working on this
so it's a retail customer
um who has as you can imagine a very
standard legacy on-prem data center
and like many other customers who are
looking at that stage
how can they modernize their stack how
can they be more cloud friendly
take care of capabilities like uh cloud
bursting and horizontal scalability and
things like that
so when we first started talking to them
this is how
major portion of the stack looked like
so they had this whole
huge uh legacy on-prem e-commerce
software which was a huge monolith which
had all the capabilities from the
customer management system
to search to shopping cart everything
built in
and then there were as part of the same
solution they had a bunch of
applications like web apps mobile apps
and whatnot
which would then consume those services
on the back end
via apis keep in mind here both the
front end and the back end were part of
the same
solution suite so this was uh this was
the current state
from where we we started our
conversation from and
what were the challenges the customers
uh facing and what were they trying to
solve i guess
from this state itself so um i think
there were uh
two uh challenge one was i think that's
the pain point which they had
for a long time which was uh the front
end and the back end was very tightly
coupled
and so the thing was like the front end
they have a very different
pace of innovation they have a very
different technology stack there's a
very different mindset of the developers
who are working on an ios app
versus someone who is working on the
shopping cart's
e-commerce system so there was a
friction for a long time
about all of that like the the fronted
guys they were not able to
you know went faster fixing bucks faster
they did not have enough flexibility
uh and it was and there was a constant
tension across
across these different teams which had
been breathing for many many years right
and uh but i i don't think that was kind
of the tipping point
uh their tipping point was for various
reasons a few years back they started a
couple of years back i think
they started seriously considering cloud
and they wanted to go to cloud because
things like they want to do horizontal
scalability for the
peak days like uh black fridays and
whatnot and
not over provision capacity for around
so
once they started looking at that then
this this very tightly coupled
monolithic architecture became a real
problem
that i think that was the first tipping
point that hey
we need to do something about this
architecture if we have to actually
embark on this cloud journey
so so in fact there were two parts of it
right
one was the agility and being able to
innovate quickly
and that was being uh current because it
was based on an old model of
architecture it was becoming very
difficult for the applications to do so
right
and i think the second one that you
mentioned was around the scalability
right scalability as well as all the
other benefits which cloud provides
once they wanted to kind of uh you know
take advantage of that then this become
a problem
scalability the horizontal scalability
so that no over provisioning
on demand scalability all the added
security which they get
in cloud all those things became a
problem so how did they actually
begin their journey so one of the first
things they did was
they inserted apigee and uh in between
those client and the and the back end so
apigee is a
is a facade as joey mentioned previously
so their idea was that
we already have those apis why is how to
decouple them
insert apigee and create this facade and
now
suddenly there is uh there is an
abstraction between what the clients are
consuming the client applications
are consuming and what the back end is
producing
so now what they can do is they can
change the back end
and then inside the apigee layer they
can transform
the the payloads the the security
protocols
the error codes and all those things to
match to what the client applications
actually actually are looking for so now
apigee becomes a flexibility or the
agility layer if you may
be using which they decouple that
front-end
applications on the back-end this huge
monolith
awesome and then what are what other
things uh did apogee provide
seeing as we're now proxying the traffic
between the application and the
system you know was analytics something
that was important
yeah exactly right so because once you
insert apigee in and once you start
having all those api calls or the first
thing they did was
uh they looked at the analytics and as
the as a lot of api customers do because
using analytics they could first for the
first time they could see
which one of the services which are the
apis are getting called
at what frequency what can be considered
as a as a
low time down time to move some
something over
uh which apis have the most problem in
terms of which is taking the most
highest latency
which has the error rates uh being
higher which has you know
all those kind of matrix and based on
that they decided their whole
whole business journey that which of
those services can be migrated when and
and so essentially that journey started
from a deep
look at analytics and it took many many
weeks
when they created many custom reports
and and looked at many other standard
reports
which apigee provides to understand all
those aspects from error rates latency
uh traffic patterns how does it vary by
geography how is it varying by
different uh different clients like how
is it varying by android versus ios
versus web
all those things also looked at it
that's what helped them decide
how they can migrate something to cloud
so even just by simply putting apigee
as the facade layer as the proxy between
the api requests
the customer was able to get deep
analytics insight
and use that to help them plan the path
to cloud
exactly the next step obviously was then
to start
breaking down some of those uh
capabilities yeah and that was the whole
idea right so what they wanted to do is
they wanted to uh they wanted to
refactor
this monolith they wanted to get out of
the monolith and take some of those
individual services and put them in gcp
and google cloud platform
so in this case you can see that they
have done that with search
but you'll see the search is also on
frame because in this stage
i'm showing the scenario when they were
just in the middle of transitioning
right so they have they said he factored
the whole service they're running that
on on gcp a brand new service
but the legacy service is still running
on-prem now they're using apigee kind of
to first and foremost facilitate
almost like a blue green deployment so
that they route some traffic to
gcp some traffic to on-prem and then at
some stage when they're confident that
the cloud
service the refactor service is good
enough that's when they migrate
uh or that's why they route all those
api calls to
gcp instead of routing them to on-prem
uh but also you can see the other beauty
is now they can break out an individual
service out of the monolith
and the client applications they don't
see the impact and that's the biggest
benefit
so the client applications the guys who
are writing
who specialize in angularjs and writing
those web apps
he doesn't see all these changes
happening behind the scenes for
him those clients this is completely
transferred now as they move
to gcp and they they build this thing in
google
kubernetes engine all microservices they
are writing new
uh new standards of the api so
everything is just one of the rest
and all those and new security standards
and
and then apigee is transforming all of
that to the legacy
or to the what are the standard which
the client applications
um expect to see right so that's the
biggest advantage that as you start
moving average access of blueberry
deployment
uh facilitator if you may and then
you know uh it provides all that
flexibility into
uh and to basically bring together the
legacy
interface and the modern interface
together awesome
so as they progress they would then you
know start deprecating certain things on
premise so
by removing say search from their own
premise right
and then start looking again using
things like analytics to understand
what would be a good candidate to move
into into into cloud
yeah yeah exactly right and and i mean
now
in this case we can see that in this
scenario uh they had couple of services
in the cloud and some services on-prem
but the front-end applications
they they don't see all that movement
happening behind the scenes and the
beauty is what we actually
saw since now the front-end developers
they have more flexibility
instead of actually slowing down they
can actually went ahead and they created
new
apps on the front end because now they
know that
oh this is my api definition and this is
the api definition against which i'm
building everything
and this api definition is not going to
change every time
some small thing changes on the back end
previously that was a big challenge
right if
if they do an upgrade of any of the
services or of that e-commerce platform
or
or anything there was a big probability
that the front-end
apps will will break and that's where
the front-end developers spent a lot of
time to make sure
whenever the back-end thing changes
their things did not make so by creating
an
api first strategy that gave
the customer an ability to innovate and
create new apis and services
and then be able to implement them using
whatever technology they changed and a
few apps
i mean uh they were kind of stuck at
having those like android and ios apps
that are pretty legacy technology for a
while
because they just did not have time
other than
uh other than firefighting other than to
comply with the back end because
it's the same engine at the end of the
day which is supporting their stores
as well as their e-commerce engine so
there were requirements for all sides
which will
shape that back end which the front-end
guys had no
control on they would always be a
reaction reward so
that left their uh mobile apps on the
web apps in a
pretty dire state uh it was pretty
legacy technology they did not have
like native uh android app and
uh there were need for a couple of other
applications like for the b2b
scenarios and things like that so
finally while
all this back-end kind of mayhem if you
he is going on
that's when they were able to you know
roll up their sleeves and and
build some new applications and and
improve and modernize
the existing applications awesome and
then
inherently you know a question that
always comes up is by
introducing another layer is what you
know what sort of uh performance
challenges or if any we're kind of are
you talking in terms of like latency
yeah latency um yeah so
uh i don't think we showed here but as
you can imagine the retail there are a
lot of services
like um like catalogs and
like customer data and that's why
location and all of that data uh all
those things are cacheable and apigee
has a very powerful caching layer with
level one and level two cache built in
wherever that was possible uh
they actually used the apigee cache and
that actually reduced their latency
quite drastically now in some other
cases which are like
uh which are which cannot be cached
which are
time for example the actual shopping
cart um
or or let's say recommendation because
recommendations constantly change
um those things whether there was a
latency at yeah
maybe right but keep in mind like in
those cases we're looking at apis which
were taking
few seconds from the app to the backend
to do all the stuff and go back
and then apigee's latency add was like
single digit milliseconds
right or double digit milliseconds right
so like 20 30
milliseconds in that range and given the
amount of
benefits which we are getting like a 30
millisecond
bump compared to a three second uh was
was not considered much
yeah and obviously there were a huge set
of apis huge set of services for which
there was a
huge huge performance bump wherever they
could
use the caching policy which is built in
uh one other thing i
might add is although it might not look
obvious
like as you are going through a journey
we started off with a lot of heavy apis
which was so which were xml and as we
were going through the journey the apis
were
a lot lighter they were like they were
they were json overdressed we are
lighting lightweight
microservices so it's part of the
overall journey
the the roundtrip of the latest of the
apis
became a lot better than what it was
previously awesome
and then i can imagine as well with the
caching that's
uh an interesting use case because now
if you're returning a response from the
cache
closer to the application that's
consuming the apis
you could potentially be servicing more
transactions
because you're not necessarily hitting
the back end system
so yeah that's actually a great point so
one of the
challenges they had was so the back end
when that ecommerce engine was built and
the whole infrastructure was built
that was built thinking of of the world
with a browser first approach web world
which was like oh this can have let's
say whatever x number
of calls simultaneously yeah 10x number
of calls a day what not
they did not think inherently the mobile
first approach
and the scale which mobile brings in
yeah right
so and they had severe problems with a
lot of outages
at various different times slow
performance and things like that
especially during peak hours
um they had all of all of that right so
as they were able to cash
in apigee using the l1 and l2 layer um a
lot of those performance worries at
least for some of those services like
uh shopping uh sorry uh like product
catalogs and all yeah
uh those were drastically reduced yeah i
can imagine in today's world even like
with google assistant
yeah google homes yeah yeah that's
another avenue another channel that is
that blowing up
no one no one thought of those yeah
those avenues like five years back
yeah so in this particular diagram in
the final state
there's an interesting thing here where
you are actually
opera the customer is actually operating
in both google cloud
and in their own traditional customers
can you share with us some of the
yeah so so uh what happened is
um at the end of the day they decided
that they will migrate
and rewrite and whatnot most of the
applications
in cloud but they were not going to
rewrite shopping cart
the shopping cart they're going to
maintain in the existing ecommerce
solution on-prem because it is a very
complex piece of software
and they did not see any business value
by rewriting it
so uh as they were migrating and we
talked about the previous slides
apigee was the layer behind which they
migrated
but not only that average was the layer
which created the hybrid
at the final state right when so their
final steady state will be
they have their shopping cart
application on-prem and they have all
the other applications as microservices
and whatnot and gcp
and then apigee sits in front which then
routes traffic to either gcp or to
shopping cart based on
based on different logics put inside
apigee so
this is actually averaging helping in
creating a hybrid
state between on-prem and cloud using an
api first approach
so normally when you think of hybrid
customers start thinking in terms of oh
i need to do
uh i need to set up a vpn and i need to
set up a vpc i need to
do set up an interconnect all those kind
of things to hybrid
yes that will be true in some scenarios
in other scenarios if you do an api
first
paradigm if you do an api first design
for applications you can do a hybrid
like this and this is something we
actually see um customers do quite often
not only
just in one scenario we have many many
customers who are doing
uh this kind of hybrid uh deployments
that that that's a
uh amazing story i believe this was
actually done in a quite
a short period of time as well um
yeah i mean the overall
i don't i honestly don't have the whole
uh time frame in mind but the initial
thing uh the initial uh proof of concept
the initial first migration of the
application and whatnot
was achieved within just a few months
now
you know as you can imagine there are
all these different pieces
that needs to be moved that needs to be
rewritten and
tested and run so that so that's a
i mean i would actually realize that
that's a pretty decent project
but to prefer this concept and to see if
we can take like
one service out and rewrite it run it on
google kubernetes engine
plug that to apigee and then expose a
set of apis
a coherent set of apis to all the client
applications that was done in
actually a very short period of time in
like a couple of months
i think it's like a month a little more
than a month and that actually amazes
the customer
they did not expect yeah um i mean not
meaning to trivialize it but
i'm just i i guess the question is how
much longer would it have taken
do this for like so many years i mean
they were they had this e-commerce
this on-prem application for so many
years they couldn't do it yeah
i mean it's not that they just it was
the first time they
thought about doing this they have been
thinking about doing this for a while
because they had all these challenges
for a while so i mean without having
this layer as apigee
at that layer they couldn't even they
could have actually achieved it
yeah yeah they couldn't even think about
taking it
yeah amazing all right um
thank you for sharing that with us yeah
absolutely so with that
we're going to actually bring it up to a
q a session now
um so if there's any questions please
feel free to speak up or you know type
it into the chat channel
and um you know let's open it up thank
you absolutely
thank you all right so we're just gonna
wait a couple more minutes uh as the
questions come flowing through um i can
already see a couple
have already come through so just give
me a minute okay
so we have a question here in this
particular case is apogee running on gcp
or on-premise for for this
particular customer in this one it was
actually running on gcp
and we are managing it as a service for
our customer itself
naturally apogee is also available as a
on-premise deployment
so that you can actually choose to
deploy it into your own
data center or into your own private
cloud as well
okay we have another question how do you
see and suggest to
users of apogee in a multi-cloud
environment so
i'm going to try and integrate this one
a little bit so
i guess the question is how would you
deploy
apogee in a multi-cloud environment um
again you can either choose to use
apogee as a service where
apigee google would actually then
provision you an instance
and then we would then manage and
operate that instance for you
now you also have the ability to then
also choose to use the on-premise
deployment
to deploy into your own data center or
into your own private cloud
and then have that manage your api calls
and mediate and broker between the two
environments or multiple requirements
itself
the questions are flowing in very fast
so hopefully i can get through
a lot of it okay so
um will this be available post uh
post event yes it will be uh we will
follow up with some emails around that
itself okay so we do have some repeat
questions uh
so another one here is where is the api
manager sitting
uh when we use cloud and on-premise i
believe that's been
answered in this particular case we are
hosting the api
uh platform itself okay
so we have another question here
and the question here is customer
database seems to be a common hybrid
component
but complicated with firewall issues and
data residency
how have you solved for this so
it it's a number of factors so some of
those things
you know might be an issue with moving
to the cloud
so they might actually have to sit on
premise so if you
uh recall back into the actual
presentation itself
our customer actually left one of their
components in the data center
which was in shopping cart which is
actually handling the credit card
payments themselves
now with customer database that can also
be the same case
where the database itself would need to
live on premise
but you would expose out an api that we
would then manage as part of the api
management platform in apigee
to then provide security and control
over who uses that particular api
itself we have another question here how
do you secure the connection between
on-premise application and apigee
so if you're using our managed services
itself
we have two options and you know some
customers choose to use one
or the other or some customers use both
and typically what they do
is they use ipwhitelisting where we can
provide you a
range of ips and they also use mutual
tls where the certificates are
provisioned to ensure that
only apigee
gateways can talk to your data centers
itself
okay we have another question for google
cloud does apigee provide adapters
hooking into
google kubernetes engine so i don't
believe we have specific adapters for
gke today but we have actually something
called extensions which
have now started being leveraged to
connect to
gcp services so things like pub sub
bigquery aiml are becoming
extensions that are becoming available
and as we create more of these
expansions and connectors
our cloud customers can then leverage to
further integrate with
uh and extend the applications using
gcp okay we do have another question um
can
we do monetization using apogee yes
we can um monetization is a module
uh that sits as part of the platform
so we do have customers that are
leveraging uh monetization today to be
able to
uh you know open up a new digital
revenue channel
and then uh leverage that capability
itself to do things like reporting all
the way up to
actually charging uh the customers that
actually want to leverage their apis
can you talk about internal usage of
apigee between internal applications
and or services um great question so
um internal usage and external usage
are different but at the same time it is
actually quite
similar in that developers you know
whether they're internal or external
want to have similar sub experiences
between
actually accessing apis so if you have a
look at you know what's available out in
the market today
there's always a developer.company.com
where
apis are published for people to
discover and understand and subsequently
also be able to test with those apis
immediately
they also want to be able to do things
like self-service where they can request
full
access to to the apis and have it
automatically generate
you a api key for say a sandbox
environment itself okay
is there an apogee certification program
absolutely
so we offer courses on coursera and
that also gives you a level of
certification we do have a more
expensive certification program
feel free to reach out to apigee to find
more details about it okay do we have
documentation on this kind of setup
if you head over to our documentation
page
we do have the on-premise
documentation which talks about setting
up apigee on-premise
in this particular case it was a cloud
managed service and it becomes more of a
configuration
rather than a um
than a you know been a complete setup
itself
okay do we have integration with
kubernetes and istio
great question so for folks that don't
know uh kubernetes is an orchestration
engine and recently there was
a new project that has come up called
seo
istio is what we call a service mesh
tool which helps you manage your micro
services within something like the
kubernetes
infrastructure now apogee itself has a
integration with istio where you can as
you can imagine you have
tons of these micro services within your
kubernetes
infrastructure but you also want to be
able to then manage some of these
services
as apis so as part of the istio
extension capabilities we have built an
adapter
between istio and apigee where you can
take some of those
microservices and actually manage the
term through
the management platform within apigee
itself
uh for more details just do a uh
go to our apigee documentation site and
there is an
istio section specific to that as well
how to monetize products
so apogee is a complete api management
platform
and as part of that we do have a
monetization module
so you can actually create what we call
different great plans
against different api products these
products can then be
something that you make publicly
available or you
push towards specific consumers
they can be defined as you know as
simple as a bucket
where a consumer would need to pay a
monthly charge
or you know it can come up with more um
you know exotic sort of plans where
perhaps it's tiered
where you know the first tier they would
pay
x amount and then you know once they
exceed a certain amount of
calls they would then be charged less or
more depending on what type of models
that you're trying to do
the question is this specific to just
retail organizations
or is this something you are seeing
across all industries
and verticals that's a great question
and it is across all industries and
verticals
um you know retail is something that we
see a lot happening
but naturally across financial and
health services as well
they are getting more and more
comfortable with cloud
and therefore they're actually starting
to leverage you know apigee
as a platform to help them move and
modernize
into the cloud and before and
just something else um i was told to
actually push
i kind of forgot is um as part of
today's webcast
we are actually uh you know selecting
three uh webcast attendees and actually
giving them
uh next passes so next is google cloud's
annual three-day conference um it's
going to be
hosted in san francisco which takes
place
on april then live to the 11th this year
so our team itself will be contacting
three of our lucky winners
by early next week and you know
giving them the passes so keep an eye
out on your emails itself
how does this help in traffic management
um so apogee as a complete api
management platform
has you know a number of policies that
actually help you with traffic
management
so things like quota are available
and also um you know where you can
actually define
things like you know x number of calls
per month
per day per minute it's up to you what
you want to define
we also do have things like spike arrest
which helps you smooth out your traffic
so kind of think of it as a way to
prevent
ddos calls into into your
platform we also have
things that can actually improve
performance so things like caching
are available as part of the the
policies to
actually allow you to define what your
keys are
and then if a request comes in with the
same
you know same request same key apogee
itself can serve the traffic out
into it back back back into the api
consumer itself thereby avoiding having
to go all the way back up
to the back end system to retrieve do
you normally
need a service mesh like istio if your
microservices are on pcf
no so sdo is a new way of managing
microservices in a mesh we have
a ton of customers that have built
microservices on pcf
and actually pcf or pivotal is a
partner of ours and we have built
integrations between our platforms
to ensure that as you're building our
microservices and deploying them onto
onto ecf you can also leverage apogee to
provision what we call an edge micro
gateway or even use their full blown
edge proxy
to to secure those microservices itself
check out our documentation page for
more details
all right so we do have a question here
do we have quick labs to try out some
concepts and labs on sdl gke and more
we we actually run these api jams
quite often so keep your eye out on
the events page for the next
api gem which also can include these
components as well from there you can
actually play with it for free
can apigee help in versioning of the api
absolutely
so there are different ways of
versioning apis the one that we see most
common
is actually through putting the you know
b1 or v2
in the url or uri i should say
and that gives you the ability to then
deploy multiple
versions of the same api as well
internally within apogee you also have
the ability to
leverage something called revisions
where we keep a copy of your previous
deployment of an
api proxy which gives you an ability to
then
roll forward grow backwards as you need
okay what is the adoption rate for istio
with apogee as
of today we have customers moving to a
service mesh
so we certainly have customers that are
leveraging things like
kubernetes and then naturally they're
looking
at istio as well there are a small
subset of our customers that are using
istio in
our production but uh they are somewhat
more
uh limited because at the rate
uh at the current stage istio is fairly
new
but what every one of our customers are
doing
especially if their kubernetes are
adopted
they're actually now experimenting and
making sure that they're keeping
you know in sync with what's happening
with with istio
uh what's happening with istio and
apogee and you know service measures in
in general
um i think we are going to be coming up
to the end of this session itself so um
you know with that i would kind of like
to thank you all for attending today's
event um we will answer your questions
in the chat channel um but
uh let me just promote our next event
itself
so um we run these events uh
you know by bi-monthly so our next event
is going to be around
understanding you know how developers
are today's
king's king makers and we have anon
jingram
who will be delivering the session on
how this trend is not only growing
but how to actually create an ecosystem
around your developers
with an api centric mindset thereby
kind of like encouraging more and more
of your developers to actually
leverage the power of apis itself okay
and then lastly if you are not
a current apigee customer or if you just
you know exploring the market itself uh
please feel free to actually sign up for
a free trial on our platform
uh we offer a ton of documentation we
offer a ton of our videos as well on
youtube for you to be able to understand
how you can actually leverage
apogee to manage your api
program itself and then with that thank
you very much
and have a good day
you